[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the show where we talk about
your relationships your mental wellness
your career your jobs your money and
your life it's called the ramsey show
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five
two two five one of the beautiful things
about having a career as long as mine
has been over 30 years now of doing
these various things talking about money
and life around the world
and on the air here for coming up on 30
years not quite yet is that i've gotten
to see a whole bunch of very very cool
milestones occur
and today is one of those brand newly
minted uh ramsey personality has been
with us for under a year but has just
been on the air a couple of times with
me for a couple segments is now
officially one of our co-hosts joining
me today is christina ellis we've
introduced her to you before she is
absolutely incredible she's going to
answer your questions along with me and
george and rachel and loanee and coleman
and all the people we put on here
probably left somebody out but um i
think i got most of them
anyway we're here and you know we have a
whole series of co-hosts that do this
show uh with me and together sometimes
when i'm not here and christina joins
that bunch today she is a brilliant
brilliant lady uh and uh so she'll have
a lot to add to your life a lot of
comments that'll a lot of wisdom that'll
help you
and i i think it's probably a good idea
i know we've done this before but on
milestone day i want to take a second
and
let our audience one more time hear your
story the the short version of your
story because it's really really
important because our stories are what
bring us here
our stories are what um you know what
allow us to answer these questions
because you can get a degree
uh and still not have any wisdom but uh
when you've got a story now a little
experience you start to get to s some
wisdom so let's go back to your mom ends
up raising you as a single mom after the
loss of your dad yeah my mom she is such
a wonderful mom she's super motivated
and believed in us completely and she
actually sat me down my freshman year of
high school and she said christina i
love you and i believe in you but
there's just no way that i can support
you financially once you graduate from
high school you got to figure out your
own way to pay for college she's a
single mom she's a widow your dad passed
when you were seven years old seven
years old after a long and painful
battle and she was an immigrant she was
venezuelan venezuelan yeah okay yeah so
even though it was really hard to choke
that down i knew that she was just
trying to help she actually said
christina if you work hard enough now
you can go to college and start fresh
completely debt-free with scholarships
and i didn't really know how that could
happen at the time i wasn't a perfect
student i wasn't a star athlete so i
just i was kind of confused at how i
could win scholarships but she had so
much belief in me that i somehow started
believing in myself and i started doing
a ton of research i read every book
every article every magazine i could
find on scholarships and i put together
a strategy and i went for it i worked
hard throughout high school i built up
my extracurricular activity list i did a
ton of volunteer work and then my senior
year of high school i treated the
scholarship application process like a
part-time job i just applied applied and
applied and thankfully that hard work
paid off it led me to win over a half a
million dollars in scholarships five
hundred thousand dollars
okay hello
yeah
but you can't go to school without
student loan debt you told me right some
of you people out there and i think she
just mic dropped on you right there okay
so 500 000 and you go and get a degree
in
yep human and organizational development
and business planning and
entrepreneurship then went on and got a
master's in education in education okay
yes completely debt free thank god so
now we have another graduate level
ramsey
uh personality because i mean deloney
has two phds i have you know a phd in
dumb i've got a one in life experience
but uh now unofficially and uh uh and we
can't make as much fun of vanderbilt
because you graduated from vanderbilt
i did graduate from yeah
i got to take it easy on vanderbilt if
you got your masters from vanderbilt and
paid for it all with scholarship money
completely paid for with scholarships no
no student loans and wow so and so we
ran into christina years ago she became
a part of the
uh the borrowed future documentary we
had her talk to teens as we were working
on this whole student loan debacle
crisis epic failure in our culture she
was one of the voices out there saying
you don't have to you don't have to you
had a best-selling book on the same
subject of how i got a half million
dollars in scholarship money and uh that
was about eight or ten years ago and we
uh have you know we've remained friends
and then you joined the team it's been
under a year right yep right about six
months about six months ago and uh she's
been uh has been a part of our extended
family for some time and so she knew the
ramsey answers
to your money questions in addition to
the student loan stuff and so we knew it
would be really really easy for her to
come in and
definitely become our in-house expert on
don't take out a student loan because
you really can't deny the story that she
has lived
uh but also just become yet another
money personality along with george and
rachel to be able to answer your money
questions and your life questions which
we all do here
as well and so she's been working with
uh dr daloni and ken coleman and the uh
on the career piece and on the mental
wellness piece and also with our
leadership team here and now we're ready
to uh have another co-host
congratulations welcome thank you i am
so thrilled to be here such good stuff
such good stuff so you need to expect
big things from her and uh and expect
her answers to be accurate because they
will be uh as she answers your questions
all across america right now she's been
on media
for the last two weeks doing media all
over the nation uh the interviews are
absolutely uh astounding um but you had
good media training from back when you
had the best-selling book before you got
here yeah i've been out there for a
while working with students and families
just fighting this toxic student loan
industry trying for a long time to tell
people you don't have to take out
student loans to pay for college there
is another way and thankfully i've been
able to work with thousands of families
around the country and help shift their
mindset to help them see that you don't
have to go to college with debt you can
do it debt-free
so fighting this toxic culture is
something she was doing and we are doing
and so um man it just it made a natural
natural fit so we'll take your calls
it's toll free and nationwide right here
on the ramsey show the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five uh if you do have a student loan
question we certainly have uh one of the
world's top experts here um and i'll
speak into it too just because i have
i'm like an expert on my opinion and
stuff so um you know you call in but
we'll talk to you about whatever you
want to talk about as always the phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five it's common sense for your
dollars and cents and you know i i think
to me i mean i'm impressed with the
master's degree from vanderbilt that's
an impressive thing but i think being
raised by a widowed single mom from
venezuela probably qualifies you to give
answers more than just about anything oh
what can you imagine i mean the wisdom
that that woman and the hard work ethic
and that's the thing that she instilled
a work ethic in us that helped us tackle
anything that we faced and i think that
is the biggest key to success is being
willing to fight no matter what
obstacles stand in your way yeah and she
she didn't tolerate excuses she was not
an excuse woman
[Laughter]
she's a getter done warrior princess i
like it that's as good as it gets this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
best-selling author ramsey personality
christine ellis is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
jacob is with us in uh wait a minute i
hit the wrong button jacob is with us in
decatur illinois hey jacob what's up
hey dave hey christina how are you guys
doing better than we deserve brother how
can we help
hey christina this question's uh more
for you i'm a 30 year old see it didn't
take but one call for you people to cut
me out of the show
just one call and i go straight
christina you're all we need now i like
it i'm so rejected no i'm kidding jacob
go ahead uh i'm 30 years old and i'm
thinking about changing careers
me and my wife have decided that it's a
good idea for me to change careers but
we
we both want me to get scholarships and
just being 30 years old i'm having
trouble finding scholarships for people
wanting to change careers so where would
be a good place to go to go and look
because i just find stuff for kids
coming out of high school for
scholarships well jacob what do you want
to study
uh nursing
and what do you do right now
i'm in the trades
awesome well you can definitely find
scholarships way beyond high school i've
met so many people who've applied for
scholarships all throughout college and
gone back as adults i want you to one
start looking at scholarship databases
you can narrow down exactly the criteria
that fits you so type in nursing type in
going back to school look for unique
qualities about you that will help you
stand out and you can plug it into those
databases it's basically like google for
scholarships so definitely start there
and then i as basic as the sounds
recommend a basic google search where
you type in those unique qualities like
nursing comma scholarships comma going
back to school
and that often yields really great
results now also being somebody go four
pages deep when you do that right don't
take the first three clicks on it
right definitely and also look into
programs for people specifically going
back to school with your state a lot of
states have programs that are for people
who are returning to school returning
students and sometimes hospitals have
programs where you can work and get
tuition benefits while you're actually
working for the hospital so there are a
lot of options for you out there and i
just encourage you to really dig deep
and explore all those options but you
are definitely on the right track yeah
the other thing is is that you are
entering a field that is known
for paying for stuff
nursing there's been a perpetual
shortage for decades and a lot of the
medical field a lot of the hospital
companies uh will pay for you to go to
school now you're gonna come you know
it's gonna be an indentured servant
program so to speak you're gonna promise
to go to work for them as a part of the
thing um or if you could get at a
certain get you know get a certain level
of certification get your foot in the
door become an employee they'll pay for
you to finish your school and that kind
of thing so the the big hospital
corporations like hca those kinds of
guys there's a lot of those guys that
are willing to pay to do that so if
you're in a field that has high demand
the potential employer may do it
and also consider looking at colleges
that are potentially tuition free
especially if you go with community
college first you know there's a lot of
community colleges that offer two years
of free school and if you're a nurse you
can maybe start with you know a two-year
program to get your feet wet because you
haven't done it before and you can
figure out in that two years is this
something i really want to do um is this
really the direction i want to go with
that career shift yeah find out if
there's some kind of an associate's
degree that precludes
or that is a prerequisite for nursing
that will get your foot in the door
again
and work your way through like that so
that all of that will work the great
news is is the field you're entering is
wide open
a lot of people have left the field
because they've been driven out by the
vaccine controversies
and
so there's a lot of need a lot of need
and so
you're probably going to find assistance
from the industry in different ways be
sure you're looking for that good
question jordan's with us in miami hey
jordan welcome to the ramsay show what's
up
hey dave and welcome to the team
christina good to good to have you on
thank you thanks i'm excited to be here
how can we help hey great uh
well got a question what would dave do
kind of question i'm 42
i'm going to be debt and free emergency
fund and all by next year at this time
and once i get back
thank you thank you very much once i get
completed with that i'm going to have to
save for a new car
and i want to do the 100 down for a
condo but i don't know if that is going
to be possible considering i will be 43
and i've got about 2 500 in retirement
right now and i'm not even contributing
to that while i'm focusing and getting
gazelle and
hitting my goals with this i'm just
worried about retirement and doing the
100 down for the house and i'm single
right now so i
you know it's just me doing this yeah so
what do you think the target dollar is
what do you mean this how much money
would you need to save
well i mean the condo prices right now
the average price i'm actually outside
of miami actually
near fort myers naples around 250 000
okay and what do you make and that kind
of
um i make around forty seven thousand
and with my side hustle i teach i make
around forty seven thousand five hundred
my side hustle is probably
about fifty
50 additional or total of 50.
no total of 50 000 a year so your side
hustle is
200 a month
yes okay
all right um
well here's the thing we don't want i i
i don't recommend is what a better way
of saying it we don't recommend that you
put a permanent stop on retirement to
save up a down payment or to save up for
a house longer than about three years
okay and so if you wanted to get a head
start on it and go okay we're going to
do baby step 3b we're going to finish
the emergency fund
go up to
three years and pile up as much as i can
pile up towards 100 down
see where we are at that point and then
start saving for retirement
uh because i don't want that in mutual
funds yeah in good growth
you could that's okay but that's not
going to be the answer the equation uh
it's just going to take you a while i
mean if you if you take if you get
uh 10 000
a year
into this account um
is that 25 years
yeah it is yeah
okay and so we don't obviously don't
want to avoid retirement for that if you
put 20 000 in it's 12 years i don't want
to avoid retirement for that long
um and so
it's probably going to involve you
putting a down payment on something and
paying it off as quickly as you can
rather than the 100 down plan or it's
going to involve you getting your income
up dramatically
okay because the ratio of your income to
the 250 000 target is what's it's what's
bogging the mouth down does that make
sense
yeah yeah it does i guess i guess i was
wondering if i should just do a strong
down payment or just a hundred percent
down i mean am i going to be okay at
retirement considering i only have two
grand right now and next year you are
just going full force okay you are if
you take three years off and save up a
good strong down payment
and then take off from 45 to 65 and you
save 15 of your income during that time
and if you never get a raise you're
still gonna be fine
okay and we know you're gonna get raised
what would you what would you what would
you get what would you guess dave if you
had to guess
well i think you can go jump on jump
ramsey solutions.com use one of our
retirement calculators
and it'll help you calculate to be exact
but i mean if you're saving 15 percent
that's 7 500 a year
uh and if you do that for 20 years
that's going to be in excess of a
million dollars
uh in your you know in good growth stock
mutual funds you know are up close to
that you're going to be retiring with
dignity and during that 20 years you
would get any mortgage you take out paid
off because we're telling them never to
take out more than
right more than a 15-year fixed rate
yep right and jordan i just love your
motivation i love your heart in this i
love that you're desiring to put 100
down that's just incredible but if you
do follow the baby steps and put you
know 15 in retirement and then get your
down payment get your 15-year mortgage
and then pay it off you're going to beat
a baby step 7 before you know it which
is really exciting so i love your heart
behind this and just where you are with
wanting to do this
yeah i agree and and i always want to
encourage people to do 100 down plan i
want you to be thinking that way and i
love that we've convinced him that it's
possible and uh the thing is when you
just look at your ratios on the math
that's what throws you
and so
you know how much can you save out of 50
000 if you could save 25 000
which was serious beans and rice after
you pay taxes and eat
right can you save 25 000 and that's
still a 10-year plan to get the 250 000
so the real trick to the equation is go
double your income dude
and then boom boom this happens in four
years and the whole discussion changes
but i don't know how you do that you've
got to decide how that works in your
career field and then what god's called
you to do
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
justin and katie are with us in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage hey guys how are you
good great welcome good to have you
christina ellis ramsey personalities is
my co-host today you're here to do a
debt-free scream congratulations how
much have you paid off we paid off
133
853.25 months wow
and what was your range of income during
that two years in a month we started out
at 82 000 and we got up to 180 000. good
for you way to go what kind of debt was
the 130 for we had credit cards two
vehicles lots of medical bills and sixty
thousand dollars in student loans you
guys were normal
very normal day very normal and you woke
up and realized normal sucks it did
pretty much man how long y'all been
married ten years
okay so eight years or so seven years or
so into the marriage
something happened and you said oh crap
this has got to change tell me what
happened
well dave uh i kind of hear you talking
about it sometime and um
or your callers are calling in you know
there was something that i wanted i went
to go get it and katie pretty much told
me said hey we can't we can't do that
and i said there's no way
we we live in south mississippi making
pretty good income why can't they do it
we have no money and she kept telling me
about this ramsay's you know the program
uh fpu and everything and i kept blowing
it off i'm like you know what i was
raised in church i've heard of dave
ramsey and
and she finally talked me into spending
the money and it wasn't you just trying
to get money from us you know it was
actually going to be helpful stuff and
when we played that first or second
video it had this guy running around on
stage and he's talking about being this
hillbilly from tennessee and he's
cutting up these cards and i can relate
to that okay
the redneck boy from mississippi can
relate to him and uh i jumped up and i'm
like that's it she's like are we not
watching no more i said no we're doing
this and i went straight to the drawer
and i got the home depot card and i cut
it up and i cut the master card up and i
said we're done with this you know and
then it was on katie you're going what
just happened i was not expecting such a
response and i didn't really think he
would jump on board so quick
and so thoroughly very much so i think
it really truly hit me that this wasn't
an impulse because two months later he
sold his seventy thousand dollar truck
that was his dream truck without even
telling me he just went and did it and
came back home and was like it's gone
whoa
what kind of truck uh it was a f-150
loaded out larry i guess it was yeah
oh my gosh hey man and a guy like you
sells your truck i mean that's that hey
katie that's that's a that's a that's a
husband yelling i love my wife that was
i love you for that i remember that
moment for the rest of my life right
there i truly felt loved
you should have and david it was on i
mean podcasts i've never listened to
podcasts in my life i was listened to
them and then all sudden march 2020 the
pandemic hits and i'm a school teacher
so
i go home and you know to flatten the
curve for two weeks i'm there forever it
feels like and i'm doing all these
chores around the house i'm listening to
your show and she's a she's an rn she's
a nurse and uh she keeps mentioning
about this travel nursing thing that
people are starting to go travel nurse
and i'm blowing it off it's like there's
no way we can do this and i start
praying about it and i'm listening i'm
painting outside the house one day and
i'm listening to your show and a lady
calls in and she's like
uh
dave i really want to do this but i
don't want this to be my long-term term
plan and you're like this ain't your
10-year 10-year plan this is your
short-term plan so i called her i was
like hey god and dave just spoke we're
going travel nursing you know so
that's amazing
who were your biggest cheerleaders in
the process our biggest cheerleader was
his mother we could not do
half the things we do without her she
constantly keeps the kids make sure
we're fed um i can leave for months at a
time and know that they're all taken
care of and i mean of course he does a
great job with the house and getting
them to activities in school but she
just constantly we are very flexible are
you still travel nursing
no actually because of financial peace i
was able to take a job two miles from
the house that pays
not as much as
nothing pays as much as travelers um or
even hospitals that are an hour away a
lot of people have to travel from where
we live because we're really rural um
but because of our peace and our
situation i don't have to i get to
choose something how long did you how
long did you travel nurse for the 22
months for 22 months almost two years
that's a long time
very long that's a serious sacrifice yes
last year i was home 28 days out of the
year i worked all the other ones 14 21
days in a row so how much were you
making doing that um up to 100 what 60
140. yeah so i mean we added a hundred
thousand to our income yeah by doing
that yeah but now you're free forever
all right so you paid a price you lived
like no one else you worked like no one
else so now you can work like no one
else
wow you all are and you get to be mr mom
oh yeah he i did how do you he
sacrificed a lot and uh
had we have four here and one that
wasn't able to come with us and that's a
lot to juggle and do by yourself
so uh yeah it is
yeah that's uh man you guys both you
guys both really jumped in and went all
in it's impressive
impressive people y'all are amazing what
would you tell people is the key to
getting out of debt
like y'all talk about knowing your why
um obviously four
out of five of our wines are here but um
surrounding yourself
with uh positive influences you know um
people that's gonna keep you motivated
and uh if you're gonna follow the
program follow the program
it's not easy you know going back to
what dave says uh him and sharing
throwing down at the house over stuff i
mean our budget meetings wasn't easy i
mean we left there mad sometimes but
we'd come back and say okay this is what
we got to do yeah you know i mean i know
it looks easy because we're standing
here now but you got to grind it out and
do it you know i know not everybody can
increase your income by a hundred
thousand but there's so many things
every store you go in right now says
we're looking for full-time or part-time
help there's stuff out there just to get
out of this season of life right after
all the hard work after all the
sacrifice how does it feel to be
debt-free
um i don't think it's hit all the way
for me um sometimes like yes taking the
job close to home was easy that i get to
um but sometimes we're we still have
goals that we're grinding and so
sometimes i forget that it's not toward
debt um but then when something comes up
like uh if new tires need to be bought
it's okay we've we're prepared for that
um used to that would crush us used to
it would take i mean i would cry and
just wonder how many more extra hours do
i have to work i mean that 82 000 we
started with was him working three jobs
and me working two different hospitals i
mean we were we've always been a worker
but now we're down to him just teaching
and me just working one job and being
home more and god's blessed us through
that process and our obedience to be
able to make more now than we were when
we started when we're working five jobs
totals yeah absolutely
very cool you guys are impressive
you're a very neat couple i'm very proud
of you okay so you decide to go on the
road travel nursing
because i travel occasionally and people
that think travel is glamorous for
people who don't do it
um and so it's uh is actual work when
it's involved in work and it adds work
to deal with tsa and deal with hotels
and deal with all the stuff so
you had to have people out there looking
at y'all like you were nuts like
questioning your sanity
look even people at church you know i'd
come around and like i said when i was
all in that's all i was talking about i
still talk about you know dave ramsey
playing what to do
and
people at church they would always joke
at me you know something about ramsey is
that ramsay approved what we were doing
or whatever you know and uh they still
do that and you know i laugh it off but
there's also people that reach out to us
that say
hey what are y'all doing how can y'all
help or what can i do you know we love
to pass on the information that's
something i'm looking in is trying to go
into the ramsey coach and you know and
uh that's kind of my future plan to kind
of do that on the side and a lot of the
kids
comes from he
he's always been a great gift giver but
i did not realize until we started this
journey how much he loves to give and we
were making more money and we're in this
journey and i get focused and i'm a
planner and so this is our plan and this
is how much we're going to put toward it
and he'll be like oh this family needs
their water turn back on or this family
need their dad just lost their job let's
help them out and i'd be like but that's
what we're putting toward it and i'd
have to refocus okay god and he would
just give it um and so a lot of people
reach back out and be like how are y'all
able to do that and not that they know
but um he's just constantly if there's a
need okay we can meet that or even if
it's just a small thing i'll help you
know put a little gas in your car so you
can get to work
let's bring these girls in their names
uh micah magnolia madeleine and maddox
you all like m's don't you
and the oldest macy she had jv softball
so she couldn't come okay so what are
their ages what's the range 14
10 7 5 and 3. oh beautiful very cool
well we're so honored to have y'all way
to go we got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you that's the
next chapter in your story and this is
134 000 paid off in 25 months making 82
to 180 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
if you think it's easy you're wrong if
you think it's worth it you're right
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis best-selling author
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five harrison is in dallas hi harrison
what's up
hey y'all how are y'all doing better
than we deserve brother how can we help
yes sir hey i'm calling in today uh i'm
just in a particular situation i thought
i'd seek some advice
um i'm 27 years old
i have a farm out near the dallas area
and
basically the the in-laws are moving out
onto the farm which is great we're
excited about that
and
they're going to buy essentially the
farmhouse currently on the property and
so my wife and i we are going to build
another house
and with the market the way it is and
how expensive things are
it's just a little nerve-wracking and i
personally do not want to go into more
debt so that's kind of what i'm dealing
with
okay so they are building are they
taking
they're going to buy a house from you on
the farm how many acres is the farm
uh yes sir we have 26 acres okay so
you're going to sell them a portion of
the farm that has a house on it
yes sir that's right okay and so how
many acres are you selling them
well so the way we're actually going to
do it they don't want to be on the deed
so they're just essentially going to
as long as it checks out with my cpa
from what we understand they're just
going to gift us the money um and
it's kind of a it's just an agreement
that we're going to take care of them as
they get older
and they're you know obviously they're
going to help us with with our kids and
and and stuff like that so um they're
about at retirement age uh mom-in-law
just retired so um uh dad-in-law he's
got one more year to go and then he's
done so um they're they're gonna gift us
basically what the house is worth uh and
then
we're gonna take that cash
and uh probably build another house and
so and you live in a home in town
no sir no sir we live on the farm oh you
already are on the farm
okay so is there two houses on the farm
or they're moving in with you while you
build
they are going to be in in the house
with us while we do yes sir oh this
sounds fun
not oh we've done it we've we've done it
before i i was in the military i mean we
moved around a lot we had to stay at
their house for for good chunks of time
so as we transitioned to different
places so how much money is involved how
much money they gonna give you um so
we're uh and this is kind of uh we we
haven't got the house actually appraised
we're gonna we're gonna do it fairly so
we'll actually get it appraised but
we're thinking just uh between my
father-in-law and i we're thinking 250
uh for the the house is what it'll
probably value at um so
does your wife have
siblings uh yes she has a brother okay
because he's he's giving up an asset of
250 thousand dollars for no asset
he just reduced his he just reduced his
net worth so are we going to give the
sibling 250 000
extra in the in the estate plan or how
are we evening this out exactly that's
that's going to come out through his
life insurance okay
so this is an advance on the estate plan
and in return you're gonna give so the
way you would legally do this is you
would give them a life estate to the
prop to the house
right
and i would carve it out and have it on
a separate plat
so that they have a life estate to that
plat not to your whole freaking farm
right okay and so you need to put an
acre or you know with a driveway around
it and that kind of stuff so that they
have their own place and they have a
life estate it remains yours
but they have the use of it as long as
they are alive
yes sir yeah that's what it and it would
be a legal document and you need to do
it properly because you're gonna get in
trouble if you don't now they can do
that with a unified estate tax credit
remember that phrase unified estate tax
credit without any gift tax
okay and so that their cpa or their
estate planner better yet can show them
how to do that
um right the thing that scares me about
the whole thing is there's no if this
goes sideways for some reason
there's no escape plan
right
yeah i mean we're christians we don't we
don't believe yeah i know i understand i
understand but christians have stupid
crap happen in their life too
sure okay yeah and so i don't know what
happens here and i have no idea but i've
just seen a lot of things go wrong
because i've been doing this a long time
and there's no exit strategy here if
everybody decides that you're going to
live next door
to the people that hate me now for
whatever reason that they decided to
hate me i don't think that's going to
happen but i'm just trying to be bizarre
enough and cause you to think this
through
because the only way you've thought this
through is if everything is skittles and
rainbows
i'm
sure i mean we we've we've my wife and i
and and we've had conversations like
this with them and i mean we're pretty
confident that um you know yeah you're
confident enough to move in with them i
get it okay let them move in with you
but
but i think you think this is going to
work as a matter of fact i think you
know it's going to work but i'm just
saying there's i on the two percent
probability that somebody loses their
freaking mind in this equation
i need a better legal structure
otherwise you're gonna have somebody's
gonna have a life estate to your land
that lives next door
that's in dementia or something and uh
is shooting at across the field at your
cows i don't know right i mean there's
people do crazy crap okay
so yes sir is there a rush on this is
there a rush
she said um well no there's no i mean
obviously when um when they their house
is already sold um so they're you know
within a month that they will be on the
farm with us and and so i mean we we
don't have a building yet we haven't
paid any money towards the builder or
anything like that uh so um you know we
have time that is for sure
and that's why i'm calling because it is
a it's kind of a funky situation right
so
well maybe before you commit to doing
the official transfers and officially
committing to this long term maybe you
just take a little time to live together
and see how that goes see if you really
if things pan out the way that you're
thinking and you really enjoy living on
the farm together because that is like
dave said a huge commitment and a very
long-term commitment yeah i i i think
you can do it if you want the tactical
way to do it is the estate plan uh the
life estate to the property and it needs
to be platted out the two acres in the
house or whatever it is is platted out
with its own access its own driveway or
whatever it might which might be an
easement i don't know but a life of
state and a unified estate tax credit
dodges the gift tax issue and so that's
the way you can legally pull this off um
and then you guys have just got to
really talk through
um
what happens if things go wrong here
what happens if you want to sell
because life changes
um well you really can't
because they live on the property and
the title is clouded well you've carved
off this separate idea it's a separate
plaid piece which is what i'm telling
you to do well then you could sell the
other acreage around it and they would
be left you'd own a house
with the four acres or two acres or
whatever you left with them as long as
they're alive and then when they're
alive and that they have access to as
long as they're alive so that's a reason
for carving it out
um
yeah i mean there's all kinds of weird
things happen in people's lives and we
don't anticipate them we don't see them
coming so you have to lay out things
that work in bad times and work in good
times
and if it only works with skittles and
rainbows it scares me so you gotta have
a you gotta have something going on so
good call sir we appreciate you calling
so christina the thing this is like the
um
a miniature version of that
is when uh someone calls me and says hey
my fiance and i
are getting ready to buy a house
together and i yell into the phone no
because i have talked to
more than one in 30 years
that the fiance died
ouch
and now you own a house
with your fiance's dad and mom
because by the way we didn't do a will
of course
and so her half his half the person who
passed away's half is now in their heirs
name since there wasn't a will and it
goes so their mom and dad now with your
dead fiance
parents
i mean you talk about awkward crud
and but it's all we were just gonna buy
a house together you know and then you
know it and it doesn't happen very often
it's a one percent of the time thing or
a half a percent of the time but i've
seen this and i've seen
or you know more often than that they
break up now they own a house with their
ex
and then they get married and now
the new husband or the new wife owns a
house with the ex-fiance half you know i
mean this is the unintended consequences
when but where were christians it
doesn't matter christians have scrap
happen okay so um you know that you just
have to think through your all your
worst case scenarios and have an exit
strategy
right you don't want to bury yourself
deep in problems yeah literally
and i i don't think that's gonna happen
with them i hope it doesn't happen to
them but
if weird stuff happens man i hope
i hope they have a plan this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host about 20 years
ago
i was in a bible study with a bunch of
guys and uh we were really reading
different books as they we came across
them and one of the guys brought a book
in there and i read it and it has become
one of
my top five or ten favorite books i have
ever read not counting the bible
and uh so much so that the author and i
i started talking about it on the radio
show and the author and i became good
friends
and for 20 plus years or around 20 years
now we're trying to count it up at lunch
it's around 20 years
we've been friends and been sharing
ideas and
doing things for each other and uh but
it all grew out of my love for his
writing and for this book the book is
thou shall prosper i actually wrote the
forward for the uh reissuing of the
second edition of it it's the ten
commandments of making money rabbi
daniel lapin is a jewish orthodox jewish
rabbi and um he has taught me a lot
about the bible and i've helped him with
a few things here and there too and so
uh we've learned a lot together over
these 20 years and i want to be sure to
share him with you thou shall prosper
the ten commandments making monies the
ten reasons that the jewish people in
every culture that they find themselves
in have an inordinate tendency to
prosper
and the 10 reasons are
a good jumping off point and there are a
lot of reasons that uh you and i have
overlapped over the years yes because
we're brothers from a different mother
in that sense right well in in the sense
that i think we both see scripture as
god's message to mankind
and it does change everything so i want
to talk about a couple of things and
thou shalt prosper and one reason i
wanted to have you on i knew you were in
town and i said hey be sure and come by
if you're in town because we want to
hang out for a little bit and make sure
our our current audience is learning
about rabbi rabbi daniel lapin
uh
there
even during this 20-year period of time
we've seen a deterioration
of
this view of business or view of success
the
the the success has become there's an
enemy yeah there's a a war on
success a w particularly a war on
business all business is evil all rich
people are evil all successful people
are evil and
it's gotten just and social media has
hyped it up even more
and less mature voices uh more
ridiculous voices have added to the this
this war on success
and you know with this idea that
business executives are overpaid they're
greedy and and
all all of this that the rich don't pay
their fair share and that runs contrary
to uh to a jewish belief system
yes very much so
and uh it's precisely that jewish belief
system that has uh created
what you alluded to earlier is
disproportionate jewish success with
money but in as much as you also said
earlier brothers from a different mother
and the connection
it also lies at the heart
of what max weber wrote about a hundred
years ago which is the protestant ethic
and the spirit of capitalism
it's not an accident
that that is what has created wealth in
what we think of as the west
but in in practical terms what's what
what has happened in in the country at
the moment certainly in this country and
also in many other countries
is that there has been a
a collapse of an understanding of the
spiritual now i just want to make
absolutely clear that when i say
spiritual i'm speaking from the point of
view of my background as a physicist not
as my background as a rabbi
so when i say spiritual i don't mean
holy or godly or anything at all i mean
there's good spiritual this but
spiritual just means things that you
cannot measure in a lab
and so a violin or a saxophone are
physical i can measure their weight and
how long they are a tune
is indistinguishable from a noise
according to any
laboratory instrument
what transforms right what converts
vibrating air molecules into a tune that
can make you happy and make you dance or
make men march off to war or bring a
lump to your throat all of that happens
between our ears in our brains in our
hearts and our souls and so music is
spiritual a musical instrument is
physical and so the the key question
becomes what is money
you know is it discs of metal or strips
of colored paper or how about it's the
orientation of iron oxide molecules on
the magnetic stripe on and your credit
card or zeros and ones on your financial
institutions computer
what is money and it's a really
important question because if it's
physical
then it corresponds to the laws of
physics and one of the immutable laws of
physics is that something can only be in
one place at a time
and so
this book
right here is now here with me
and if i turn away a moment and i turn
back and it's now with you you took my
book
there's no other solution
but if i um if i
teach you a tune and you go away here
with my tune you've taken nothing away
from me
spiritual things can be in more than one
place at a time physical things can't
and that's where it gets critical
because if money is physical then if you
have a few dollars you must have taken
it from other people you see socialists
secularists atheists don't comprehend
the idea of making money they understand
taking of money
it's a very very different thing
and the whole idea that money can come
into existence as spontaneously as a
tune can
is alien and so you know i can i could
sit in a room all by myself and compose
a tune and then send it off by
as an mp3 file to my publisher and my
publisher markets it and starts
collecting royalties and he can then
order a caterer to send a meal to my
room and i've produced something
concrete and tangible and physical in
the form of a meal in my room
come about purely because of a spiritual
act of creativity and so what's happened
is over the last 20 years that that you
and i have been talking there has been a
marked deterioration in people's
comprehension of of spiritual hugely
important for everybody trying to make a
living everybody trying to build a
business because a good number of the
decisions that we make in life
particularly financial decisions are
made for spiritual not physical or
utilitarian reasons
and so when a certain lady i know very
well whose name i will not reveal
drives across town because her little
app shows her gasoline cost less in
another place the fact that i explained
to it's not worth your time it's not
worth the the the wear and tear on the
car just buy the gasoline wherever it is
she says no i can't do that well she
grew up in new york she can't do
anything else that's a spiritual thing
when a person pays more money for a pair
of jeans that's got a funny label on it
why
it doesn't it does it's it's all these
are all spiritual reasons i love their
phrases uh the difference in making
money
making money means creating
you created out of nothing out of wealth
that's where my creativity that is where
money cut out of service yes rather than
taking
everyone says the fixed pie right it's
not a fixed pie yeah we'll talk about
that the fixed pile is a beautiful
beautiful
[Music]
uh metaphor that we need to unpack
rabbi daniel lapin my guest this hour on
the ramsay shop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
my good friend rabbi daniel lapin is in
town and he is a treasure as you are
discovering listening to us his book is
thou shall prosper check out everything
he has at
rabbidaniellapin.com
rabbidanielappin.com
and he's known as america's rabbi
a noted rabbinic scholar best-selling
author tv host
eloquent speaker we've spoken together
many times on stages across america and
many different locations sometimes i'm
there one week he's there the next week
sometimes he's on one of our events and
all kinds of other things
and before we jump back in into this
discussion um i want to make sure we
touch on this project you're working on
scrolling
through the scriptures yes yeah and
because it's fascinating so and they can
learn about it at rabbidanialappin.com
but briefly what is scrolling through
the scriptures and it's the realization
that uh this book is not an
anachronistic history book about events
long gone and about nations no longer
existing it is actually a technical
instruction manual on how to most
effectively live on planet earth
and and that means
being healthy physically it means having
friends it means having a rewarding and
fulfilling family life
and it means having a relationship with
money and it means having a relationship
with god and there is very practical
instruction on enhancing one's lives in
those five areas embedded within the
hebrew text now problem is most people
can't read hebrew of course but that's
why i like saying everybody needs a
rabbi
and uh even us christians especially
that's right and and you know i hate the
idea of unemployment so i submit my
candidacy for the position of your rabbi
and um
and and so what we do is we make
everything accessible
in using some amazing technology we make
the actual instruction that which has
made jews disproportionately good with
money as you said earlier in every place
and in every time of history in
hospitable countries and in tyrannical
regimes jews have always done well with
money and the information on that lies
embedded in the hebrew scripture and
scrolling through scripture is a program
that walks somebody who has no
background in the hebrew
basically a guided tour into the
wondrous garden of hebraic information
that not only makes
jews
disproportionately successful but it
actually had a lot to do with why the
united states of america has become
history's greatest engine of prosperity
because the founders even going back as
far as william bradford on as one of the
pilgrims they knew hebrew and they knew
and were able to understand and extract
practical life-giving information from
that hebrew text never been done before
this is the very first time we've done a
scrolling through scripture program so
find all of that at rabbi daniel
lapin.com you will be richly rewarded i
promise all right talk about one of my
favorite riffs is candles and cakes
yeah well it's the same as musical
instruments and music and tunes
and that is that um
money is brought into existence when one
of god's children does something for
another
now we can use the right terminology we
can call it marketing we can call it
sales
service we can call it service and
there's a reason why we have a worship
service and we also say customer service
those two are related and
and and we can look at our financial
statements as a as a detached and
vitally important set of data as to how
our business is doing but what is
important not to lose track of is that
at its root
it's service to another human being if
that doesn't happen you don't have a
business in the same way that we'd say
if you do not have profit you don't
actually have a business
you're a hobby you have a hobby that's
right it's a good that's a great way of
putting it yeah uh if your profit if
your revenue doesn't increase
isn't more than your expenses you do not
have a business the socialist fallacy is
like you said earlier if i take the book
you don't have the book and so if
they look at the economy as cake yes
that if i
uh if i get a big if you get a bigger
slice that means there's not as much
left for me
and you have taken yes rather than made
correct and that distinction in the in
the first segment was vital uh and you
say that is not how the economy works
well it's i put it this way there are
two ways of getting money into your
pocket
one way is by serving another human
being
it might be a customer client a boss
anybody
another way is using a 357 magnum
revolver
now somebody who decides to get money
that way comes home from work at the end
of the day and
his wife says honey how was your day he
says not bad you know did okay she said
how much did you take and he says you
know i i held up three people i took a
total of about 150 and some odd change
you know that's one way of getting money
and the other way is actually serving
other human beings who then give money
to you voluntarily and
the essence of business is also the
essence of being a good human being
which is finding ways
to please other human beings it's
beautiful it's a wonderful thing to do
and it's limitless absolutely limitless
that's why the idea of the cake example
is so fallacious there's only so much
cake you took too much you know you got
all kinds of things must be you took it
from me this generates envy and
unpleasantness and recrimination and
basically breaks a part of society which
is what we see happening it's not an
accident that no atheistic regime has
ever succeeded in building an effective
economy it can't happen that's why we
have the words in god we trust not on
the walls of churches but on the
currency
so instead of cake it's candles
candles you can light your candle from
my burning candle you've taken nothing
from me you've just brought more light
into the world this is the christmas eve
service yes when i light your candle you
light another candle you light another
candle you light another candle and the
whole place is beautiful now and it
started dark
but no one stole no one was diminished
that's right by passing their light
along
and by passing the service along you're
not diminished if you view money
correctly because
it is um that's why they call it a
currency is because it is a current yes
it is not a fixed item great point it's
not a fixed item right so uh changing
gears just a second before i before we
run out of this segment because i don't
i want to be sure to get as much of your
wisdom as i can get thank you um one of
the things you've said recently that has
jived again was something that i believe
is you said that a completely different
subject that leaders who are not
willing to engage in confrontation are
not leaders yes
talk about that yeah of course people
don't like hearing that because today
the whole you know uh toxic masculinity
and after all it's masculine to be
willing to confront etc etc and so
there's this huge attack on this but but
look um i think the first thing to
recognize is you know who is the biggest
villain in your life who has caused you
more aggravation through all your life
than anybody else who is it who has
obstructed you at every turn who's made
life difficult for you
i got a clue his name is on your driving
license
and he's in your mirror right he has
she's in your mirror exactly so
so
the most important thing is to be able
to confront yourself
and you know pop psychology keeps
telling us we worry about your
self-esteem i'm terrific everything i'm
doing no you screwed up
you know stop doing that it isn't any
good so being able to confront yourself
obviously is is a very crucial step in
building a business and developing
financial independence and financial
peace
you know everybody knows they shouldn't
spend more than they make so now that
that knowledge is there why are you
still around we why do we need you
you've told us what to do
and the answer is information is not
enough there has to be inspiration as
well and that is the spiritual dimension
absolutely pat lynch only talks about in
his book the advantage that a company
that creates a corporate culture of
healthy conflict yes is the has a brand
advantage over any other company that
does any other thing
you you beat smart people great point
people smarter than you every time if
you can have a mentally healthy
organization that does healthy conflict
and leaders that will not create healthy
conflict for the good of progress yes
are not real leaders
and uh they're just acquiescing and um
you get a neville chamberlain event when
you have just
that's right and uh and that will birth
the church hill yeah that's what it'll
do so uh wow it happens on the world
stage and happens uh in our little
businesses and in our little lives it's
so relevant yeah rabbi daniel lapin the
book is thou shall prosper check out his
website
rabbiddanielappin.com and please enjoy
scrolling through the scriptures you
will be glad i introduced you to my
friend of 20 years this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis best-selling author
ramsey personality is my co-host today
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to live life to the
fullest picture all your favorite
speakers together on one stage
empowering you with the tools and the
principles that create unstoppable
momentum in your life
that
is smart conference yep smart conference
is back baby been three years and we're
pumped to get the event back on the road
it's time for us to be on the road again
dallas we're headed your way saturday
october the 22nd the headlining speakers
this year will be rachel cruz dr john
deloney ken coleman george campbell and
christina ellis to my right plus our own
friends our good friends craig and amy
grochelle from life church will be
joining us talking about marriage in
just one day you're going to get advice
about every area of your life money
personal growth leadership mental health
your career it's not another pep talk
you're going to leave smart that's why
we call it smart conference tickets are
only 39 it's a great price for a full
day event like this as you know all
kinds of live events concerts and
sporting events are selling out very
quickly because human beings like being
around other human beings it turns out
so hey we're going to be doing this big
thing and there's not a lot of tickets
left if you want to come it's in dallas
and you don't want to miss it october
22nd 39 ramsey solutions.com on the debt
free stage in the lobby of ramsey
solutions randy and jennifer are with us
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve dave how about yourself better
than i deserve where do you guys live uh
shocked in ohio it's about an hour east
of columbus cool welcome to nashville
how much debt did you pay off uh on the
plan about 37 000 uh just before that we
uh kind of realized we were house poor
so we got rid of uh almost 200 thousand
dollars in mortgage before that okay all
right that's part of the story so how
long did it take to pay the 37 000 off
about 12 months good for you and your
range of income during that time uh we
started about 55 and uh when we did our
taxes for 21 we ended up about 96.
okay 55 to 96. all right cool good for
you well done i love it what kind of
debt was the 37 000 uh 30 of it was a
401k loan and said the other seven was
medical miscellaneous here and there
okay cool so tell me your story what got
you guys started on this 12 months ago
so i had always
struggled with money um we made you know
pretty decent money but i did a budget
in excel and it just it didn't work and
it just never worked i was always really
stressed
um and finally we just kind of i was
honest enough to say you know i think we
have too much house we we worked on that
um and then a friend of ours um
gave us the total money makeover
workbook
um just kind of started reading through
that and it made sense and i'm very
analytical plan oriented and i saw yeah
i think yeah i saw a plan that
sounded like it would work and
talked to my wife about it and we just
kind of got on it very cool very cool
well good for you guys i think for me
the hard part was i went from being
homeless to then we were together and
me having nothing and
so a hard part for me was literally just
getting to the point where it's like
it's okay to get rid of this
so you were before you all were married
you were literally homeless yes
and how long have you been married we've
been married now 10 years but we were
together for 12. okay so you you were
homeless literally on the streets you
get married and then a few years later
this new husband sells your house no no
we decided to get that oh man wait a
minute i'm gonna choke him that was hard
for me that was really hard like we had
made the plan to get this home because
we have seven kids and all of them were
kind of here and there coming in now
because some are older some are younger
um
and so for me it was like well i never
want my kids to go through being
homeless yeah i guess not yeah so that
was the hard part
so there was a lot of uh there's a lot
of history here and and you know the way
you started describing it randy at the
start was just this sense of
hopelessness
yeah very very much so it just
i couldn't figure out why it didn't work
because the math looked good um but now
that you know we we got into every
dollar now and looking back i
i was putting numbers on a page but it
wasn't an accurate honest budget there
was just a bunch of extra stuff in there
that every dollar helped me kind of work
through and
actually put names to everything and
kind of square us all up
that's amazing your story is so powerful
i love that you just your mind shifted
you guys went for it and now you're good
at money
so what would you say
yeah here you are what was the key to
getting out of debt for y'all use the
program that's for sure definitely use
the program um
the
every dollar helped me just to be able
to see where we were at and we linked up
our bank accounts to it and so
like he has a budget now like okay honey
it's okay get your nails done it's okay
to get your hair done every once in a
while
and so just knowing where i'm at and
that
it really does help a lot that's amazing
gave you a communication cool tool to
pull together then absolutely and i
think for me it the the plan gave us a
lot of tools
but i
i woke up one day and i just i decided
that we're gonna we're gonna make
something happen i wasn't sure how and
that that's what the plan did for us but
it i just i had to decide that we were
gonna do something different yeah and
now you so you sold the expensive house
but you bought another house you did we
did i'm making sure you're not home oh
no no no i'm never going back to that
again
no and actually the the 401k loan was
for fixing up the house that we bought
yeah the other half of the house so her
her dad passes we got some money there
put him with her forward and kayla we
actually paid cash for the house we have
now oh wow so so you are a 100 percent
debt-free how are you 30
we are congratulations baby step 7 baby
whoops absolutely looking at weird
people
yeah you guys are amazing
congratulations very good yeah for all
the people who think that they are bad
at money who think that they can't do it
what would you tell them
uh
be honest
um don't be afraid to ask for help
because that's what it took for me um
just kind of a circle of a couple
friends and we were all just kind of
talking about we were talking about you
know investing here and nuts and bolts
stuff there
and it didn't really click
but once you know i got the total money
makeover book and it just it laid out a
very clear plan that it just made
perfect sense and we were just off to
the races
yeah way to go guys we're very proud of
you you're amazing congratulations thank
you who was cheering you on
oh i think that same circle of friends
uh tony and melissa they're the ones
that gave us uh a couple wealth books
but the workbook was in one of them
um your mom yeah saying your mom yeah my
mom for sure she kept cheering us on
yeah she thought it was a good idea to
have some common sense in her family she
did she did
i think one thing that really helped and
i know this sounds kind of crazy but
when he got deployed
that helped a lot because we were able
to get his regular income plus the
deployment pay
on top of it to just knock everything
out at once so your national guard randy
i'm part of the state defense force in
ohio it's the ohio military reserve
yeah i very much lucked out because when
i was on active duty the state pays me
as a soldier but my employer never
stopped my paycheck either so i we we
got very fortunate there and that helped
us just absolutely knock it knock
through uh three yeah it is fortunate
but it's not luck right it's called
serving your country and people
appreciated it including your employer
way to go employer yeah who's your boss
who's your employer uh at that point it
was ts tech and reynoldsburg way to go
guys yeah way to go support your people
man that's good stuff absolutely good
stuff well way to go you guys we got a
copy of the baby steps millionaires book
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure you're going to be there
and also a copy of total money makeover
you can give it away and stir up a
ruckus for somebody else absolutely
never know that'll be perfect well done
i will say
one thing that has really been nice even
just coming here
i mean this is amazing but um we were
able to do some things that i never
thought that we would be able to do
and the whole time like we were going
through things and we're like uh it
doesn't matter like we already had it
budgeted we already have that money we
don't have to worry about that
for us to just go and be like hey jack
daniels how about a 200 bottle of wine
this is the first vacation ever that i
haven't been sitting at the end of the
day just crunching numbers and figuring
out if we're still okay or if we need to
start skimping down yeah it's amazing
well when you don't have a house payment
or anything
uh you can you can afford the jack
daniels absolutely
[Laughter]
way to go you guys all right randy and
jennifer columbus ohio area 37 000 paid
off in 12 months but quite a story
making 55-96 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Applause]
i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i do
you may read it
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run all
the time you'll save even more always
use the magic word the promo code ramsay
to get the best deal
today's question comes from phoebe in
duluth i am 21 years old and working on
getting my teacher's certificate i work
three part-time jobs so i can graduate
debt-free i recently got engaged and my
fiance is currently in undergraduate
school with a plan to go to med school
after we get married his parents are
currently putting him through undergrad
school so he will graduate debt-free as
well our plan is that while he is in med
school i will work full-time and he will
work part-time we'll start paying off
his med school student loans before he
even graduates my question is what can i
do now to keep the student loans to a
minimum and start to save money
that's a great question phoebe there are
so many things that you do and i love
talking about this topic of course my
go-to is always scholarships i was able
to win over a half a million dollars and
just put myself out there constantly
treat it like a part-time job how hard
is it to find a scholarship for med
school
it's harder than undergrad which is
challenging but they're still out there
and often called fellowships or there
are specific programs that have benefits
and are a bit cheaper than others so i
always encourage people to dig deep i
feel like so many people instantly say
it's med school there's no scholarships
out there for that and that's just not
true
i got accepted here
but i uh
and this is the place and no matter what
it costs i got to go because i got
accepted here right and did that that
that could be triple the cost of another
med school right and how often do you
check your doctor's credentials none
of the time
right you know i i've never i've never
gone to a doctor and said no you you
really can't take that mole off of my
head
because you went to the wrong school it
never came up right you didn't go to an
ivy league so i'm out yeah it doesn't
happen
right so you got to think outside of the
box be willing to bend and be flexible i
mean especially with med school we're
talking potentially hundreds of
thousands of dollars so be willing to
look outside of even your state if it's
a bit cheaper be flexible be willing to
be strategic well for 200 000 bucks
would you move yes yes
temporarily to go to med school in
another town you bet you would
you would lift your tail end up and go i
mean it's you know you got a fellowship
the md phd programs are like they work
like a fellowship and that's a way to go
through med school they're very hard to
get into it's a very elite
uh class that goes to that and that is
very much grade based and very much
academics based and so on but uh but man
the the um duke has one as an example
that that their med school but it's if
you can get into those you go free and
by the way the military will send you
through free
yep that's definitely a great way to
look at it we've talked to several
military doctors who sometimes there's a
service commitment but if it helps you
graduate debt free and you get
experience that's like a double win
but i love the way that they're thinking
i love the way that even at a 21 years
old phoebe is already thinking through
you know how can we plan this out
because that's part of the problem is
some people so many people are not
looking ahead they're just thinking this
is the degree i need right now this is
the path that i have and i'm going to do
it at all costs but the fact that she's
stopping and saying hey we want to do
this in the future but we're going to be
really strategic at every step of the
way is huge that's not what a lot of 21
year olds are doing right now well and
one of the things i learned to do about
the whole debt subject in general is
just say
um
okay
i don't borrow money
period
now what
and if you take it
as an option take away the option of it
and you go well i just can't go if i
don't figure this out you suddenly start
figuring out a way to you find a way to
do it then
but if you go well i'm just going to
limit the pain i'm going to limit my
level of stupid stupidity i agree with
you i really like that they're looking
ahead and that they're 21 years old but
i would challenge you to treat it like
you can't go unless you find a way right
well that's part of my story is so many
people look back and they're like were
you trying to go debt-free did you have
this big strategy to avoid student loans
and honestly my mom was an immigrant
from venezuela we didn't even know about
student loans when we started the
journey i thought if i was going to go
to college if i was going to go to
school that i had to figure out a way to
pay for it either
you go figure out a way to pay for it
then right that's the only option there
was no other option yeah and so we do
meet people that come through here from
time to time and and i will admit
they're fairly rare they're harder to
find than undergrad but i meet people
that have graduated from law school and
people that have graduated from med
school several times a year
debt-free and it wasn't parents paid for
they figured out a way to get someone
whether it's scholarships fellowships
whether it's md phd programs whether
they sign on with the hospital whether
they sign on with the national guard
whatever it is they're doing they find a
way
to not be 300 000 in debt when they come
out of med school
and they start their life with a big
income potentially
but in a big hole right and that's the
thing that i think they sell a lot of
times with degrees in general is they
say you're going to have this huge
income so obviously you're going to be
able to pay it off it's no big deal but
that's just not true you know we saw in
borrowed future the orthodontist who had
a million dollars in student loans and
even though he had a great income that
was hard to pay off he was overwhelmed
he was in tears like even though the
income was huge with that amount of debt
it is stressful i was in tears and it
wasn't even my dad
it's unbelievable man the poor guy it
was it was just heartbreaking so hey
that that's the thing so kudos to you
phoebe for looking ahead as christina
said
i and and studying but we're challenging
you to even go one step further and be
radical and say okay let's just take the
idea of dead away as even an option now
what are we going to do
three heartbeats later your brain kicks
in and the lump drops out of your throat
and you go figure out a way to do it and
i'm gonna challenge you to do that
because people are able to do this and
let me tell you 100 of people that start
med school do not graduate they don't
have 100 graduation rate
can you imagine taking out that dad and
then not making it
and then not making it this is yeah
everything's not rainbow and skittles
baby this is how this works all right
amanda's with us in washington dc hi
amanda how are you
hi thank you so much for taking the call
um we inherited a home worth 400 000
in 2009 that we used as a rental
property and we sold it last year for
425 000.
we contacted our cpa before we sold it
and he was told we would only be taxed
on the capital gains
of the 20 000 difference that's correct
so we just got our
well we were really shocked we just got
a tax bill for 52 000
for depreciation recapture oh well
there's never heard of okay so you you
appreciated the property while you were
there while you had it
yes exactly and so um we're 40 years old
our oldest is finishing sixth grade
you sold the house
for 400 000 where'd that money go
we used um the
majority of the profit to pay down our
current mortgage
okay so how much money do you have in
the bank now
we
we don't we don't have any well we have
our emergency fund of 35 000. you didn't
have a 52 000
tax bill you had a 52 000 increase in
income that they paid that they charged
you taxes on
from
right from the depreciation over 12
years of owning the property
so um we're
trying to know if we should use our
emergency so the tax bill is 50 grand
yes
52 000
and you have 35 000 to your name
for our emergency fund where else do you
have money
i mean my we have um you know money and
retirement but as far as you have any
money that's not in retirement
no our liquid assets are
um the emergency fund
what's your household income
um my husband is a nurse he um
so he picks up as many extra shifts as
he can he works about an hour away and
so
um he approximately when he's able to
work four to five days a week he brings
home approximately six thousand a month
okay he's going to be working a little
more i'm putting the 35 000 on this and
we'll put the rest of it on payment plan
with the irs and i'm going to pay it
hard now i'll go get an a i'll take out
a home equity loan for the balance uh
you're already in debt to the irs i'm
just restructuring your debt to a
different kind of debt i'm not telling
you to borrow money but you're in debt
so put 35 000 on it borrow the rest on a
home equity loan and pay it off in three
months your husband works 24 7.
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
christina ellis ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your job
your career your relationships your
mental wellness your
money your wealth your whatever you want
to talk about your life it's what we're
here for the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
shadrack is in utah hi shadrach how are
you
hey dave i'm good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
so my wife and i are
thinking we're hoping to buy a house in
about five years
um i'm a junior in college i've also
been working full time
as a software developer for a year now
and
we
have
thirty thousand dollars um
saved beyond our emergency fund
that we're planning to pay for
a master's degree i have a really
inexpensive program and
our next car
so our next thing is we're saving for
this down payment
and we're wondering
if we should put that in a roth ira
and what the
advantages and disadvantages of b
now i do not use roth iras to say for
house down payments is that what you're
saying
yeah yeah i wouldn't do that no
um i you know i would just put it in a
something like an index fund an s p 500
fund and let it sit there
if it's gonna sit there five years
that's a long enough period to ride the
waves of the market out
um
but um and you'll make a little money on
it the truth is that in a five-year
period of time the amount of money that
will grow or the amount of taxes you
would save screwing around with a roth
or whatever it is
is not really what's going to get you
the house
when you actually run the math out
you know you know let's say you say 50
000 bucks okay
and it makes ten percent a year all
right that's five thousand dollars a
year five thousand dollars does not get
you into the house the fifty thousand
dollars gets you into the house
and so the fact that you save money
and don't spend it is where your house
down payment comes from it's not from
the whoopty do investment and it's not
from the
uh whoopty do tax savings okay so it's
not tricking the system that gets you
the money it's you putting the money in
the stinking account that's what does it
so that's how you're going to get there
way to go man how old are you
i'm 23.
impressive i love it hearing your junior
in college and you're having that four
four thought is amazing you guys are on
a great track yeah and you're gonna make
some bank as a software engineer man
what are you making now
right now i'm making about 55
um as a junior developer yeah i'm
i'm increasing that with side work and
i'm hoping after another year or so to
pivot to a new role probably at a new
company and
hopefully increase that by 30 or 40k oh
yeah you will if you're dev1 and you
keep increasing your
uh your your skill level to dev2 dev3
you know you're gonna you're gonna
triple that easy
uh if not more depending on you know the
area you're in and so forth and why are
you getting a masters
in this
what does that give you so
i'm uh i'm in an information systems
program and they have an integrated
fifth year master's program where i get
a master's of information systems
management what does that give you
though in your world because
you know i've got i probably got uh 300
developers working on my team
and i've never i've never considered
whether they have a master's or not it
never comes up in the hiring process all
i want to know is can they do the code
sure
um i've in talking with some
some people who are a few years into the
field now and are are looking into
management positions they've a few of
them have expressed that it's given them
a leg up on their peers who are now
feeling need to go back and get an mba
or something okay if you're going into
leadership and into management then i'll
go with the masters right if you're
doing this to get if you're doing this
to me to do code and to be a software
developer no i wouldn't i wouldn't waste
my money
okay
you see the difference because the map
because the masters is not going to
increase your code
your your your ability to code your
ability to go into the upper echelon of
coders
sure and start doing platform and
architecture and all that that's you
don't need an information systems
masters to do that your search will do
that and you know and hands-on work in
the environment that you're already in
will do that the only reason i know this
is because i have a whole bunch of them
on my payroll like millions and millions
of dollars worth of them and so i've had
i've had to learn it because i give them
a lot of money so i kind of wanted to
know what the flip was going on so that
that we do not hire people now we do
have some people with graduate level
degrees in leadership and i'll go with
that that that does assist you in that
process but the uh the computer world
the information systems world is not a
postgraduate world by and large
right well i think it's amazing that
he's working at the same time so many
juniors in college are just kind of
coasting still and he's making money too
right so he's gaining experience and
it's you know even if he gets that
master's degree if he keeps rising
through the ranks in his job he's going
to really win when he gets in the
workforce absolutely very very very well
done open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five i understand
what you're doing now go for it shadrach
by the way i agree with you have at it
brother and uh don't don't get too far
ahead of yourself on buying the house
let's get this education stuff finished
get this career going and then we'll get
over there and buy that house but um you
know the trick to saving money for
something like that on the short term is
how much you put in not how much the
investment makes
i got to tell you christina i'm excited
about dr john dolone's book coming out
next week this is uh
this book has been we've been talking
about it in pre-sale for quite a while
and this is a book that is it's as if dr
deloney is sitting across the table from
you doing personal counseling with you
when you read the book and and i've read
a lot of psychology books i mean
i love that field and i've read a lot of
them done a little bit of post-grad work
myself a thousand years ago in that
world and i just love what he does i
love how he does it and when i read the
book i felt like he was coaching me
it was i you know i got a lump in my
throat i'm like john
you know so it's uh pretty incredible
the stuff he works with on relationships
how to have a more restful life a
peaceful life it's financial wellness
for people who aren't sick
you know or if you are sick it's okay
he'll help you with that too but you
know it's like when you say mental
health sometimes people think crazy
right and uh this is not like crazy this
is like we're all a little crazy okay
kind of book it's that we all need a
little leg up we all need a little help
in relationships we all need a little
help dealing with our story from our
past and it's own your past change your
future that's the title of the book it
comes out next week it comes with uh one
month of weekly free
therapy sessions from the folks at
betterhelp it comes with the audiobook
version the ebook version it comes from
all of this with 20 if you pre-order the
book
you do not have but six days to
pre-order the book it is coming out next
tuesday you will have missed all these
free goodies
so go order the book right now we will
give you the stuff and ship it to you
next week
and all for 20 bucks
and i just i promise you this is going
to change the way you feel the way you
look at your life in the past the way
you look at your life in the future and
it's touched everyone who's read the
book including me i've heard some
incredible testimonials from people who
thought you know i'm just reading this
to be nice to john but it changed my
life it's rocking man yeah really good
wonderful ramsey
solutions.com
you got to get john dolone's new book
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
well tax season's almost over and some
of you still haven't filed what are you
going to weigh the last minute you're
the worst that stayed up all night doing
your term paper in college weren't you
you need to do your dad gum taxes and
get them done right now taxes aren't fun
to start especially when you realize
what some of the big tax software
companies are up to they say you can
file your taxes for free but then when
you get in there it's not really free
it was only free for the person the
version that you didn't get
it's a problem hey there's a better way
to do it ramsey smart tax and stop
procrastinating it's our own tax filing
software it's made to do one thing and
it helps you get your taxes done right
no hidden fees no sleazy offers trying
to get you into debt no salesmen will
call and you get every federal form you
need up front no gotcha charges no up
charges no zings
simple
and this year if you use the promo code
tax 22 you can get an extra 25 off it
doesn't cost that much to start with you
just need to get this done ramsay smart
tax ramsay solutions dot com slash smart
tax to get started
and file without the surprises
smarttax
andrea is with us in kansas in wichita
kansas hi andrea welcome to the ramsay
show
hi
hey what's up
well um i am just i have a question how
can we help our son go to college if we
can't pay for it
how old is he
he's 18. he'll be graduating next month
oh wow okay so like this fall huh
yes what's he want to study he wants to
be a chemical engineer and in kansas
there's only four colleges that offer
that program and three are private and
one is a state school so of course the
state school is going to be the cheaper
route yeah i think
yeah like a fourth
yeah okay
so why does he want to be a chemical
engineer
he has always just enjoyed
science math and chemistry is something
he absolutely loves and
it's great
he has
almost a 4.0 uh 3.98 he's number three
in the class
um
he's yeah he did really well and so
you're in luck christina ellis is my
co-host today she found a half a million
dollars in free scholarships so she's
going to answer your question
yeah
well you said that there are four
schools in the state what's what's his
current plan
so
he
he wants to go to k-state and he has
applied
for every
scholarship that he has um or he that
he's found and that he's eligible for so
he is mad at us because we actually make
too much money right now so he doesn't
qualify for a lot of scholarships
and um
so you don't want income based
scholarships anyway
there are a bunch of those i know but
christina got a half a million dollars
worth and none of them are income based
oh okay so i guess we just need to be
pointed in the right direction because
what we are finding is not
well i love that he's got such strong
grades a lot of schools they list their
merit-based aid on their website so if
you go to the financial aid website they
actually haven't listed out how much
merit-based aid because he's a strong
student i would encourage you to even
look outside of the state and see if
there are any schools where he can get
really high automatic merit-based
scholarships based on his gpa and test
scores especially just being a strong
student that's just
an easy first place to start
do you know how much merit scholarships
he's been offered at the four schools
he's applied
uh
to
hundred dollars yeah
i would definitely look outside look
outside of the realm look outside of the
box and see if there are other schools
in other states um even just getting
online and looking up you know chemical
engineering programs that have massive
merit-based scholarships you might be
surprised i mean between 50 different
states if you open up your search
parameters you'll probably find a lot
more options where else should they look
for scholarships i would definitely go
to some scholarship databases a lot of
people go to one scholarship database
and then they get discouraged because
they don't find scholarships that match
them but i typically recommend people
use at least five different scholarship
databases because not every database is
going to match you with all the
scholarships that you are eligible for
so if you use several different
databases you can compile a list that
actually applies to you plus there are
millions of scholarships available so
you can't take the time to apply for
every single scholarship so you want to
find targeted scholarships that fit you
and are within your niche so especially
with him wanting to do engineering
scholarships there are a ton of
stem-based scholarships there's a lot of
engineering-based scholarships so i
would really narrow in and search within
that field of his interest and where he
wants to go
andrea uh what do you guys make
uh well i'm a teacher
what's your household income it's a
simple answer our household together
right now is a hundred and twelve
thousand last year okay and why are you
broke
um because we were dumb and tried to
live with the joneses and have um
we have seven about seventy six thousand
dollars in debt um with our student
loans so you guys are working to clean
up your mess is what it amounts to right
now
yes we are
baby step
here's what i think happened and you
tell me if i'm wrong
okay
i think an 18 year old wandered into the
freaking fafsa nightmare
filling out those forms
and whatever dropped in his lap he took
and what drops in his lap is student
loans the first thing they gave him on
the merit based and a bunch of pell
grants that he didn't qualify for and
then he called it a day and walked away
yes he's pretty nervous yeah zero
perseverance
and well he has that he has been trying
to apply to scholarships that we've
heard of it okay but we just yeah but it
doesn't you can't apply to three
yeah
133
okay okay and the other thing is this is
i i'm okay i don't think it's lacking in
manhood on his part for his mom and dad
at 18 years old to put their arms around
him and even go over to k-state and sit
down with him and go hey we're about to
send this kid somewhere else and he's a
freaking almost 4.0 because you bozo's
hadn't stepped up
and meet with the counselors over there
and and just jack them up a little bit
and you may find 10 grand in one
conversation
okay do that and and you know and then i
want you to be his biggest cheerleader
one of the things christina had was a
mom who uh
uh gently or sometimes not so gently
encouraged her to fill out a scholarship
application every freaking day
okay and was like her accountability
partner and was up in her grill about it
i can do that and that's what i i kind
of think this kid's out there wandering
around doesn't know what to do by
himself and i think he would benefit for
to for you to distribute some of your
strength to him
absolutely well and a lot of people feel
like they're applying for a ton of
scholarships and whenever i boil it down
it's often like 10 or 20 and then they
get discouraged that they didn't win any
scholarships based on 20 applications
and it's like i want you up how many did
you apply for i applied i got very
fortunate i applied for a little bit
over 50 but now i recommend kids to
apply for hundreds of scholarships the
market has gotten so much more
competitive it's like put yourself out
there i saw a stat recently and it's
like i believe it's like
students win one in every 20
scholarships that they apply for so it's
like if you have applied for 10 you're
not even in the running right now like
you gotta up that plus if you already
got one out of your 20 then you need to
do 20 more and then you get another one
and that's the averages there you go so
that's the kind of stuff we're pushing
for the last thing is this k-state's not
that expensive
junior can work
while he's in school
i mean you can make serious money
walking dogs you can make serious money
cutting grass
you can make serious money delivering
pizzas
and you can work it's not child abuse
to work well he's in chemical
engineering it's difficult it's
difficult to be broke too
it's difficult to be in debt too
work is not child abuse as a matter of
fact when i'm hiring here at ramsey and
i our team is hiring here at ramsey it's
not me it's somebody else doing it here
but but you know somebody who's actually
worked while they're in school
they get an a in the hiring process
someone who's never had a freaking job
but is really really smart
it's a little more of a risk because we
might be the first person to actually
teach them to work and that's a scary
thing and this is what employers really
look at in the real freaking world here
well there are stats out there that
actually say that kids who work in
college do better grade wise which is a
win-win i mean they're walking away with
work experience plus their grades are
better no time to play beer pong right
yeah there you go that's how that works
who knew
yeah this kid's a good kid he's smart
anybody looking at chemical engineering
he's probably not a problem like i was
but
you know but yeah get up there with him
you guys walk through this i'm going to
send you a book uh
a debt-free degree by anthony o'neil
that's a ramsey press book it's going to
help you with this and get you going
give you some give you some angles and
thank you so much for calling andrea you
can do this it's just going to require
some effort and it's less effort than
paying off the student loans if he took
him out after he graduated this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
christina ellis best-selling author and
ramsey personality is my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage rasa is with us hey rasa
how are you i'm good dave how are you
better than i deserve where do you live
um during my debt-free journey i was in
philadelphia in philly where are you
today i am a digital nomad so i've been
traveling um digital nomads so you live
on the internet i live i i airbnb
i'm kidding okay you became an avatar i
did never met one okay
all right how much debt did you pay off
kiddo 64 000. 64k and how long did that
take you about two years and 11 months
two years and 11 months very very good
and uh what was your range of income
during that time about 60 000 and my ote
this year is 160.
so 60 to 160. yeah yeah nice nice
nomading
well done nomad
so what do you do for a living i'm in
customer success with a tech firm okay
all right so and you can do all of that
remote okay which allows you to just uh
travel the world it does so and today
camping out in nashville to do a debt
free stream i like it yes very well i
love it good for you what kind of debt
was the 64. um there's about 12 000
in credit card debt and the rest was
student loans okay so what started this
journey two years 11 months ago so
i got let go two years in a row on the
same day so the thursday before
christmas and boy your business sucks
yeah well that that wasn't it wasn't
following the right path at the time
it's full of sharks it was rough i mean
who fires people two days before
christmas in an industry twice in a row
oh my gosh
exactly and um
it
it kind of knocked me back as you
imagine um i had already booked a
vacation and so i didn't enjoy it
because i'm
you know i was unemployed at the time um
making some real deep reflection about
not wanting to be in this position in
the future
and so
the second half of my um
my vacation was actually a meditation
retreat
and up on the mountain you don't get a
radio signal
coming down the mountain the radio
kicked in and it was you
no
i swear
and so i listened to you the whole way
home and random radio signals is my
biggest promoter exactly
um and i listened to you the whole way
home and i was just like yeah this is it
um jumped online found financial peace
university locally bought your book and
it was just
it just clicked it made sense um it was
hook line that was game on like i was
just ready to go at that point wow yeah
and then you land a new job
yes and then you land a new job yes it
was actually two jobs just like that it
was
i got focused on my money and realizing
that i wasn't valuing myself
and i just got i mean to use y'all's
words intentional i was intentional with
my money it was month over month
grinding it out and then reviewing month
over month what is it working for me in
my job what is it working for me in my
income why are my peers making more and
it was because i wasn't valuing myself
and i just started making different
decisions
and um yeah and and kind of the rest is
history i love my job i'm
just the weight off my shoulders you
know since i've been debt free i paid my
last student loan payment and then i hit
my digital nomad life the very next day
and it's just
it's been wonderful that is amazing i
love that level of intentionality that's
just that's super powerful what was the
hardest part of your journey
um
i think in the beginning it was what
felt like such a huge mountain even
though i was really convicted and i knew
i could do it
it just
it felt so long you were really
ambitious in the beginning and you're
like yeah i'm going to take my budget
i'm going to do everything right i'm
going to be debt-free in nine months and
it's like
then the the heater goes out and then
and then a dog get injured and then you
know but i was able to cash flow nearly
20 000 worth of emergencies
during that time which was probably
the more empowering piece of it because
um life kept happening over the three
years i just handled it i'm 41. okay
because this sounds like that um the
money piece
was
about 10 of the transformation yeah
that's the other ni 90 the
transformation for you was career
spiritual
psychological mental health
everything you you became you came out
of this a brand new you for sure and the
money piece is just a little part of the
journey really absolutely it's a big
it's a big journey and we're getting to
hear a part of it with the debt free
screen completely that's what i think
i'm hearing absolutely wow powerful so
proud of you thank you well you had to
have people cheering because that that
type of all-encompassing transformation
is uh
it is more difficult than simply paying
off debt
because it it's uh your guts turn over
several times inside of your body and
reform a different you when you're done
i don't know how to that's not a good
way of describing it probably but it's i
mean i i went through it in a sense when
we went bankrupt it was it was a
spiritual thing it was a a relational
thing it was a psychological emotional
thing and it was a money thing
and so i just reached a point like for
instance i used to really worry about
what people think and as of going
bankrupt i don't care what they think
anymore
and i really should care a little bit
more but i just don't care at all it's
awful and for 30 years it served me well
so i don't care at all but that was part
it really wasn't a money thing it was uh
i gave up this need for affirmation from
people i don't even know which is stupid
in america we do it at a level that and
social media than never before record
levels we do that and when you give that
up you can you can do in your case
though you had this whole thing you
valued yourself and it changed
everything it really i could see it we
can see it on your face
can't you yeah it's amazing you're
glowing thank you
who are your biggest cheerleaders um my
friend crystal who's actually here with
me today um my um my mom of course and
then my sister she was probably my
day-to-day cheerleader um she would she
would be the one that i would confess
when i like fell off the wagon i'd call
her or text her and be like oh god
dave's gonna be so mad
like i personally knew yeah like i knew
that girl up there in philadelphia look
at her
pop up on the radio
i'm all powerful
but the funny thing is is that like um i
would fall you know everybody falls off
the wagon like it's it's not like if you
haven't like congrats but you do you
fall off the wagon you make a bad choice
you fall into old habits and and i would
be like oh dave's gonna be so mad
and then i would jump on every dollar
and i would do it clean up my mistakes
and re-budget everything and realize
that i could just
let it go and move forward and and and
just keep trucking and that was
just instrumental you got to feel like a
completely different person because you
are a different person i am and it's
it's i i i want to encourage so coming
down that mountain i remember a very
specific caller and like this is a ton
of fun and i highly encourage everyone
to do it but but hearing yourself and
other people's stories um share your
story with people because you don't know
who's going to hear themselves i've got
people dming me on social media just in
my private circle asking me questions
and that's been the best part about this
journey is being able to help others
truly
yeah so you know the radio comes into a
signal and there's somebody on the radio
with your exact situation yeah yeah
that's called god doing that yeah you
can't you can't that's not coincidence
pretty impressive your life sounds so
interesting now how does it feel to be
debt-free and to have the freedom to be
a digital nomad and travel it's
wonderful so it's a
there's not a map for it right so
growing up you you you see things
modeled for you but like being a digital
nomad was not modeled for me growing up
in the 80s and 90s and so it's i've been
able to craft the life that i want to
live that's right for me like this time
around and
the freedom to do that and to fly home
and be near my nephew if i need to or i
spent a month in florida closer to my
father who i don't haven't lived in
proximity with in two decades and and
being able it gives me the freedom to
make different choices
um that you know serves serves my heart
and and my soul and i just i could
couldn't be happier
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure we're very proud of you
congratulations you're an impressive
young woman very very well done also a
copy of total money makeover for you to
give away and then stir up a ruckus with
somebody else that'll be good too so
good stuff very good stuff
rasa is with us from uh formerly from
philadelphia now she's from god knows
where and uh paid off 64 000
in two years and 11 months making 60 to
now 160 and uh the best kind of homeless
i'm saying this is what we're saying
right here so count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three
two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
well i'm going out at the break and meet
my first digital nomad i've never met
one before this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalms 27 1
unless the lord builds a house the work
of the builders is wasted unless the
lord protects a city guarding it with
centuries will do no good
william arthur ward said four steps to
achievement plan purposefully prepare
prayerfully
proceed
positively and pursue
persistently
and the other one is learn to say your
p's in a row my goodness
wow i don't know if i could get all that
out there a little bit of alliteration
can you help me with that william arthur
award wow all right let me see if i can
do it again plan purposefully prepare
prayerfully proceed positively pursue
persistently i did it nailed it it
sounds like a voice coach exercise
to see if you can hit those peas that's
pretty impressive
[Laughter]
all right i've got to get out of this
kevin's in houston what are you doing
kevin
hey dude can you hear me sure what's up
uh um so
i'm calling in uh i've been in a little
bit of a pickle trying to decide what
loans to pay off and whether or not the
pull out of investment accounts that
were set up for me when i was younger
my buddy brandon recommended uh actually
just calling
on your show which is why i'm here now
i've got
right now i've got
actually when i look at it total quite a
bit of debt um
95 000 total
13 of that is a car seven of that is
federal student loans 42 is private
student loans
and i'm paying just a little bit over
minimum on most of those i round up to
the next hundred
but i am well what's the other 40 grand
oh sorry uh 40 is uh
private student loans now you said 32
you said 32 is student loan seven with
student loans the 13 was a car
oh shoot i'm mixing them up 32 is a
rental property that i own it's a house
that i don't live in that i rent out oh
okay 42 is private student loans okay
now i'm there now i'm the 95. okay
yeah i'm caught up with you and how much
money you got in the bank from all these
different things um
so
between my checking and what i consider
my emergency savings i've got
uh ten thousand
um nine thousand that's sitting in kind
of investment accounts and some of that
was set up before i was even
able to talk
and then
4 000 that i had earmarked for some
travel that i was trying to budget and
save ahead for
okay so i got like i guess what i'd call
like 23 000 that's
scare quotes available
although some of that's the emergency
fund yeah so it's like i've got like
twenty thousand and it's like do
um i currently make about 64 000 a year
base salary i do get overtime and some
bonuses which i usually
throw into savings okay
uh the
your your friends sent you into a bear
trap
so i because i could tell by talking to
you that you've you're not super
familiar with everything we do
um and so i'm going to be super gentle
okay
is that okay i have red total money
makeover believe it or not oh i feel
like i'm definitely half assed
everything okay well you definitely have
yeah without a doubt okay then i'm not
going to be as gentle okay
i'm i'm going to love you well kevin i'm
going to love you well um so here's the
thing
you've got what you've got to decide is
are you going to keep doing what you've
been doing
you have to decide it right now but you
do need to make that decision
because you know
as you said half-assed doing it doesn't
work
it's you know being a half-butt it gives
you half a butt i mean it's just that
you're not going to get there so the
thing is
if you study the data which we have done
over the years with what millionaires do
people that become millionaires starting
from nothing and you have the potential
to do that
the first thing they do is they clean up
their debt
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and so once
you make that decision and you say all
right
i want to become wealthy and the
shortest distance between where i am and
wealth is to get rid of the debt then
debt becomes the enemy once you
put that set of assumptions in your
brain do you agree with that
yeah do you agree with that i think so
okay
if you if you if you say the shortest
way to something
is
x then x becomes the thing right
if the shortest way to lose weight is
drink more water then drink more water
becomes the thing
you follow me yes absolutely okay so
you either decide that what we teach is
right or you decide it's not right and
you go find a different way of doing
your life and that's okay i'm not mad at
you for that but millions and millions
of people have followed this exact plan
and we've got data to back it up and
we've got lots and lots of case studies
to back it up that it works
so
given that yeah you're not traveling
anywhere you're freaking broke so your
little travel fund goes on your debt
and you list your debts smallest to
largest you take six extra jobs you
don't see the inside of a restaurant
unless you're working there and don't
talk to me about vacations you're
working all the time you are a broke guy
and you need to clean this freaking mess
up and this is how i talked to myself
when i got out dude so i'm going to talk
to you this way because i love you and i
want you to win
all right
so you list your dead smallest largest
and you attack them with a vengeance
what's this rental worth
um so it's a single family house
50 it's about 50 000 in value good sell
it
sell it
it's a crappy little house it's a cash
flowing property it's a crappy little
house it's a lot of hassle in your life
you're not cash flowing 100 bucks when
all the smoke clears and repairs on it i
own real estate there's no margin in
this deal you got a 20 or 30 equity
position and there's no margin in it
and it's not it's not it's not the
answer to your wealth building i want
you to get real estate later i want you
to pay cash for it but right now it's a
distraction and it costs you money when
the smoke clears are very very close to
it it certainly costs you your time and
you're making a dollar an hour screwing
with this thing so you need to get rid
of it list your debts smallest to
largest and get in attack mode and you
could be debt free in like 14 to 18
months if you do what i'm talking about
and you follow the total money makeover
but you got to decide if you want to do
that or not not everybody does
les brown uh christina les brown the
great motivator said people change their
lives when they finally say i've had it
i've had it i'm not doing this anymore
yeah and i think it's great that he
called in because he's in a great spot
to make that change right now while 95k
in debt sounds super intimidating when
you break down a situation it's like he
can do this pretty quickly if he sells
the rental if he pulls some of those
investments from when he was a kid
that you know he could go towards that
debt he's in a great spot but like you
said he's just got to make that decision
and go all in gazelle intense yeah i
forgot about that other 20 grand so we
sell the rental it gets rid of 30 of the
95. i got 42 i got seven i got 13 and i
got
1923 in
the account i gotta hold a thousand for
baby step one so you got 22 to throw to
this so the car's paid off the student
loans are paid off the only thing left
is the 42 in student loans yep
and he can do this
and whatever whatever you make on the
rental you throw with the student loans
too
and you clean this freaking mess up dude
now you're out of that he's out of debt
in nine months if he gets to gazelle
intensity
but if you keep screwing around with it
half button it
it does this doesn't work it just
doesn't work if you have buddy you got
to go you have to get a different system
if you're going to do a half butt and i
appreciate that he was willing to admit
that right
yeah me too i mean because i mean the
thing is the the definition of insanity
the 12 steppers say is continuing to do
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result
so you can keep doing what you've been
doing in your marriage relationship and
you're going to have the exact same
marriage relationship it could be good
if you're if you've got a good one keep
doing it right you know you could keep
doing this parenting stuff
but i remember mom when we would be
raising cane as little hillbillies
running out of the house she would say
and the worm has turned and we didn't
even know what that meant except the
beatings were about to begin
and but that was shakespeare turns out
who knew mom knew shakespeare but um
you know but what that meant was enough
this craziness stops
and you got to do that to yourself you
got to go enough
this craziness stops i'm not going to
keep baking a cake wondering why it's
chocolate when i used a chocolate recipe
change the recipe you know and that that
when they do that christina life changes
absolutely and that's why we say that
money it's 80 behavior 20 had knowledge
it's about changing your behavior the
way you think around money and actually
shifting things exactly
exactly christina ellis ladies and
gentlemen her first day as a co-host
ramsey personality best-selling author i
love it i love it i love it very well
done today very well
and james and kelly you guys did a good
job too in there nothing you know in
spite of yourselves life's good we'll
put this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you